je présente le garçon qu'elle a
peut-être un roulement de tambour ses
marques et théo la bonne meilleur
apprenti de france en pâtisserie 2019
une vraie fierté de la région depuis
tout petit et à 10,81 paient depuis tout
petit est tombé dans la pâtisserie leur
teint pâle dans le salon c'est ça c'est
ça
raconte-moi laventure sûr c'est simple
ça commence tout petit comme on dit dans
les fourneaux avec papa ou moment la
grand mère tout c'est aussi pareil et
après la halle aventure j'ai voulu faire
mon apprentissage en pâtisserie un vrai
je suis parti du coup pour faire mon
apprentissage en chocolaterie et grâce à
mon sac et pâtissiers j'ai fait mon
concours qui m'a permis de faire le
meilleur apprenti de france était ou
avec un paquet dans le salé une amie
cadors le sale et toi tu fais du sucre
ou de faire un truc bizarre
hammami c'était le sucre est aussi away
mais alors pourquoi la pâtisserie basse
et plus rigoureux j'aime bien la
pâtisserie faut plus de dextérité c'est
quand même plus soignée que la cuisine
c'est au gramme près à ce nombre et ça
va faire plaisir à papa qu'est dans les
coulisses il ya quand même des cuisines
et qui réalise des recettes vraiment au
métronome attention attention à ce que
tu dis bon alors la pâtisserie ça a
donné quoi pour devenir meilleur
apprenti de france qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pendant ce concours raconte moi
paul aventure balle avant sur saha était
donc déjà c'est beaucoup d'entraînement
avec mon patron que j'avais une
entreprise sur le creusot donc mon
patron qui m'a beaucoup appris mais un
priore comment faire donc les entremets
les biscuits pour lui rendre hommage
c'est dans le duché si nous regardent
tout en haut avec paul bocuse il doit se
dire tiens mais je suis super fier nous
a quittés à 40 ans était un grand
chocolatier des régions vous le
connaissez certainement saône et loire
mais je suis sûr que maintenant vous
allez connaître ce garçon qui finalement
digne héritier de cédric de faire comme
je peux
c'est super alors les fierté sont là toi
tu es spécialité c'est quoi c'est plutôt
le fruit c'est plutôt le chocolat moi je
vais plutôt fruit d'accords très bien
j'ai un couteau ici tout le monde se dit
mais bon alors si on regarde dans les
détails effectivement des meilleurs
apprentis de france n'est pas encore
tout à fait le meilleur pâtissier de
france mais ça va pas tarder on pourra
lire tient la première fois c'était sur
france 3
effectivement voit des petites choses
mais ça c'est normal n'empêche que pour
construire un gâteau qu'on soit
pâtissier meilleur apprenti il ya des
règles tu sais comment tu les dessine
d'abord tu prends des recettes tu
t'inspires ah ben moi c'est beaucoup je
suis allée coutts et on me dit c'est
très souvent je prends la recette qu'on
me dit de faire ou après j'essaye
d'amener un peu ma touche sur le décor
est chose comme ça c'est un peu là où on
a plus de liberté mais sinon sur l'autre
mais c'est vraiment ce qu'on me dit tu
permets que j'ai vu que jean coupe un
géant coupin ici la tient pour jc
laquelle juste devant pour qu'on voit
quand même la dextérité de ce garçon à
prendre c'est ta philosophie de vie
t'arrête pas de prendre il faut toujours
apprendre 18 ans j bravo 1up d'un
déficit ne pas faire attention j'espère
qu'on a bien vu j'espère qu'on a bien vu
voilà vous voyez quand même dextérité
tu apprends pour aller vers quoi nous
faire quoi plus tard bah moi déjà
j'apprends c'est pouvoir vraiment
acquérir un savoir enfin pour ma passion
et aussi pour dans l'avenir pouvoir
travailler dans ma boutique qui est mon
propre patron c'est ce que tu voudrais
faire que ça très bien tu m'as dit
plutôt les fruits mais tu aimes bien le
chocolat aussi est-ce que c'est un
éclair au chocolat st non c'est par là
marie thérèse garcin dommage ok mais les
éclairs au chocolat c'est pas un éclair
au chocolat
donc ça sera pour moi dit dont on a vu
là sur celui que j'ai coupé plusieurs
étages
ceux qui nous regardent se disent ah oui
quand-même des tâches c'est pas facile à
faire c'est toujours facile sur les
livres dans les recettes mais quand on
le fait chez soi laitages il a un peu
quelquefois il manque l'ascenseur quoi
alors on fait comment bah c'est toute
une technique en fait donc on travaille
beaucoup maintenant avec
les congèle donc on fait en fait lente
les petits gâteaux par étage donc on
voit la terre du milieu
ouais on sait exactement on le fait
toujours
surgelé avant donc il est toujours froid
on fait notre notre mousse et une fois
que la mousse est bien mais notre insert
centraux l'appuyer pour bail qui lie
justement tout en bas et le biscuit
c'est la même chose congelé puis ont le
même par dessus
alors évidemment il faut pas faire ce
que je fais c'est à dire prendre un
couteau qui n'a pas été nettoyé voiliers
qui a encore des traces de deux rouges
sur un gâteau comme ça je voudrais pas
tous massacrés voilà je voulais
simplement voulu montrer comme ça et
vous donner envie
1up là bas ça donne envie on va on va
déguster avec vous mesdames messieurs
mais d'abord je vous emmène découvrir
une exposition surprenante
on va partir dans les coulisses du musée
d'orsay à paris paris c'est une finalité
pour toi ou tu veux rester dans la
région
non paris on verra gta semaine dernière
d'accord